[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHEN ELLIOTT: All right.
Thanks, everyone coming to
IO208, Diving into Your Billing
Data with BigQuery
and Data Studio.
I have the privilege, and I'm
really excited that my main job
here is to set the
stage for five minutes
and then get out of the way and
introduce you to our customers
so they can give--
should I spoil it?
It's a live demo for,
basically, 45 minutes.
So if you all just say
some prayers yourself,
it'll all work out fine.
I'm Stephen Elliott.
I'm a product manager
on Google Cloud Billing.
And then we have--
this is really easy.
We have Dale, site reliability
engineer at Vendasta.
And we have Dale, chief
technology officer at Vendasta.
Round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
And we'll introduce
Vendasta a bit more.
It's a global B2B company that
helps customers and customers
of theirs with marketing
and other tools
to help them grow
their businesses.
So it's a really cool
customer, and you'll
see what they do
behind the scenes.
So first, to set
the stage, I'm going
to go through a
couple of exercises--
a quick analysis by hand
of the needs for BigQuery
and looking at your cloud costs.
And then I'm going
to tell you what
we're going to talk
about it, and then we're
going to talk about it.
So first, it's kind of an
esoteric session title.
I want to make sure everyone
is in the right place.
So a quick show of hands--
how many of you monitor
or manage cloud costs?
OK, so that's a good start.
Good.
You're all in the right place.
How many of you want or
need custom dashboards
or are already building them?
OK.
That's great.
And then finally,
how many of you
are satisfied-- let's set a
high bar-- fully satisfied
by your data and
dashboards today?
Ooh, OK.
All right, how about we
lower the bar a little bit?
How many of you are
generally satisfied with what
you build today?
OK, wow.
OK, great.
You're in the right place.
And I want to start
by framing this.
We ask these key cost-management
questions in every talk
that we're giving.
And I think the nice things
about these questions are,
they're evergreen,
they're fundamental,
they apply whether or not
you're running in the cloud,
running on premises,
running a hybrid solution.
They apply whether or not you're
running pure infrastructure
or you're doing something really
cool with Kubernetes or Istio.
So first, obviously, how
much does my app cost?
You're building your app.
You want to make sure that what
it costs is less than the value
it's delivering to you.
And you can answer this
at many different levels.
You could just say, in general,
am I spending less than X
per month?
Or you could ask
yourself, how much
is this VM that's been running
for a long time costing me,
and is it worth keeping
that thing running?
The second question is, what
are the trends in those costs?
So are the costs
going up as expected,
or are they going
up unexpectedly?
Is the trend good or bad?
Growing costs are
not a bad thing.
Your costs could grow
with customer demand.
And if they're growing
sublinearly with customer
demand, that's great.
That's a great growth.
Or it grew unexpectedly
because someone
did a really fancy analysis
they didn't need to on BigQuery,
and they got an
answer that might not
have been worth the cost.
And then finally, what
are the cost drivers?
So what is it that's
driving the costs?
Do you understand them?
Are you able to
delegate cost analysis
to the right people in your
organization to understand
the costs at the right level?
And that's a lot about what
this talk is going to be about.
So before we dive in
a little bit further--
and you'll actually see a
bunch of these when Dale Birtch
presents--
we offer several different
tools on Google Cloud Platform
to help you answer
these questions
at various levels of detail.
So one thing that we launched
recently is billing reports.
So at a glance, you can
see your cost trends
overall and within specific
products, within specific SKUs,
over specific time ranges.
So you can kind of drill
down right in the billing UI
and see what your costs are.
And then we recently launched--
and we have a team for this
in the room--
forecasting within reports,
so you can see forecasts
based on the specific
configuration of reports
you're looking at to see how the
general trend looks over time.
We also have budgets and alerts.
Matt Leonard gave a great
talk on this with [? Lucas ?]
[? Carlson ?] from [INAUDIBLE]
yesterday on how to set up
budgets and alerts and receive
notifications about them,
either via email or
programmatically via Pub/Sub.
So you could set up
a Cloud Function.
You could respond to them
automatically and set up
very nice controls
in your environment.
And then finally, we
have billing export.
So this is where you
really want to get
into the fine-grain
details of your bill.
You want to understand
what resources are running,
what labels are attached
to those resources,
whether it's the machine type
or which project the BigQuery
analysis took place in.
A lot of the detail
is in BigQuery export,
and that can drive some
really nice dashboards
that help your teams understand
what's going on in the cloud.
So before I turn
it over to Dale,
just to set the stage about
what's actually going on,
this shouldn't be too--
I guess I'm right in the
middle of the screen--
let me walk over to the side.
So this shouldn't be
surprising, but, basically,
billing starts
with actual usage.
So on the far left
here, we meter the usage
at the product-level.
And what happens to that usage
is it goes into something
I'm going to call
the pricing engine.
And I have some tech leads
in here who are like,
there is no such thing.
That's not what we call it.
There are many stories way
more complicated than that.
And I'm like, yes, but I'm a
product manager, so I represent
complexity with a black box.
So usage comes into
the pricing engine,
and there are a bunch of
different pricing schedules
that we marry to usage to
produce the cost of your usage.
This should feel right.
This equation should
not be surprising.
And then there are several
places where these costs go.
So first of all, all
the costs go to Dale--
not of all cloud customers,
just of Dale's costs,
and that's via the invoice.
And then he gets to decide,
do I like this invoice?
Do I want to pay this invoice?
Am I going to pay it on time?
And generally, he has
been doing that, which
is why he's on stage with me.
So the second place
that this could go
is cloud billing reports.
And this is the way that you
can see your costs at a glance
immediately in the
billing console.
And this is meant to satisfy
many different users.
So it could be the chief
technology officer.
It could be the site
reliability engineer.
It could be the project owner.
Anyone with billing
privileges can see the costs
in their project and
billing accounts.
But what we're going
to talk about today
is the other place that
these detailed costs
go, which is into BigQuery
billing export if you enable it
and then, what you can do with
BigQuery and that billing data,
once you've set it up.
And the goal here is really
to help you measure, monitor,
and manage the metrics that
matter the most to you.
So just keep that in mind.
The three fundamental
questions-- what are my costs?
What are my cost trends?
What are my cost drivers?
And how do I set up the
queries and dashboards
that really show me what I need
to know to run my business?
Without further ado, I'll let
Dale Birtch take it from here.
DALE HOPKINS: That's all right.
One of the Dales?
So what I wanted to do is--
I guess I'd start off in that
we've been a Google Cloud
customer now for just
over eight years.
And so, you'll find
out that's actually
before Google Cloud was
called Google Cloud.
We started off on App Engine.
And App Engine had
some interesting things
about billing.
But for us, we've got about a
million small businesses that
currently use our software.
And we've got 19,000
salespeople that ended up
using our platform to
deliver those services
to their customers.
So we do have an interesting
problem in that that's actually
quite a bit of work to be done.
And so Google Cloud has
been an integral part
of our strategy in terms of
delivering that and managing
the scale.
But one of the
things that you often
don't hear about the cloud
is that, while the cloud does
allow you to avoid
availability and scalability
problems of that nature,
what it doesn't do
is it doesn't eliminate
all scaling problems.
So one of the things
you'll find is
that, when you trade out when
you have your own hardware,
is when the load scales, instead
of you paying with availability
or latency or
problems such as that,
you end up just
paying with cost.
And so the important part
is that, as your application
scales, so does your cost.
And that can scale in ways that
you weren't 100% ready for.
And so watching over
your cloud costs
is a really important part,
like one of the basics.
It's really important
to how you use cloud.
And so that's why we've used
it in a lot of different ways.
And we've used that
kind of from the start.
And it's gotten a lot
better over the years.
And specifically,
what we found is
that Google doesn't
miss a lot of things
in terms of your bill.
It's actually very accurate.
The usage is very correct.
You probably haven't found
out at the end of the month
that they forgot to
charge you for something.
And so for us, because of
that level of accuracy,
it's actually a really good
diagnostic tool for us to use.
So Dale Birtch is
going to walk you
through some of these things.
And we promise to have a live
demo that you guys can actually
follow along.
And we're going to build some
of the stuff from the ground up.
So with that, here you go, Dale.
DALE BIRTCH: Thank
you very much.
As he said, I'm the
other Dale from Vendasta.
How I got involved
with billing originally
was when we first started an
SRE team back in December 2016.
Dale came to us with a problem.
He showed up in the room one day
and said, how are things going?
And we're, like, I don't know.
Things are going pretty good.
He goes, I got this
month's Google bill,
and it was $20,000
higher than we expected.
And like, that's
probably a problem.
That's a lot of beer.
So when you equate a Google
bill to being a lot of beer,
it doesn't take
much to suddenly go
from a $60,000 bill
to an $80,000 bill,
all because of a bug that went
in at the start of the month
and nobody noticed.
And App Engine just
scaled and handled that.
We had the additional traffic.
None of our customers
saw any outages.
We didn't see any problems,
and we just got a big bill.
So that was the first postmortem
we held as an SRE team.
And we sat down with the
team, and we went, OK, guys,
how did the bug get in?
How did we review it?
What were the steps
we took in place?
And how do we stop this
from happening again?
And the team went, well, if
we're going to own a project,
we kind of also need to own
the billing for the project.
We need to know what it costs.
And we need to see
that before you
come to us with a postmortem
booking and saying you
guys spent $20,000
extra, what the hell?
So that's where I got
involved with this.
We were trying to come up
with some type of a solution
to track our billing in 2016.
And there wasn't really
anything great available.
We looked at crazy things like
scraping the App Engine status
board to give you daily totals.
We figured out the BigQuery
export at that point.
And I sat down with one of
our data analysts and said,
can you teach me
how to Data Studio?
And she kind of laughed and
went, well, even you can do it.
So that's how I ended
up in Data Studio.
And we've been using
it for dashboards
and the individual
team boards ever since.
So I'm going to jump
over here into the demo
and start at the
Reports tab and Billing.
It's important to understand
the scale of Vendasta here.
So we've got 96 billable
projects within the Google
Cloud platform--
34 Google products that we
get billed for and 400 SKUs.
So it is a little difficult
to keep track of which ones
we actually care about.
Most of the projects
aren't actually
costing us a lot of money.
They handle small services.
And most of the SKUs don't
have a large volume on it.
There's probably 10
or 12 in every project
that I actually care about
and want to track closely.
So when I look at the
dashboard like this,
I can try and drill
into individual things.
But I'm always guessing.
I'm guessing at what project
is having a problem, what area
of that project,
the product it is,
or what SKUs within that
product are actually driving it.
And yes, I can find
a lot of information
from this dashboard.
And their forecasts
that they announced
recently, we've been
using them for a while,
and they're pretty killer.
I can't match that
in Data Studio.
But to actually present
this information
to a team is
difficult. There's not
a great "I Am" story around it.
I don't want to give out
permissions at the organization
level for it.
There's no premade
reports that they can just
hit this and see the view
that they had from last time,
or anything like that.
So while those things are
coming, in the meantime,
we still have
motivation to put effort
into building our own set of
dashboards [INAUDIBLE] here.
So I'm going to start
today by building
one of those dashboards
from scratch.
So what I'm going
to do is first,
I'm going to set up an export.
So we've got
billing export here.
I'm going to go in.
And obviously, I've
already set this up.
We've been running it
for a few years now.
But it's going to say
which BigQuery project?
I'm going to have a set up
to export to-- in this case,
it's this project--
and what table set we're
going to have in there.
So once this is saved, it's
going to, going forward,
save all of your billing
data to BigQuery.
It doesn't do it retroactively.
But once you start, you can
start to build a set of data
that you can use,
then, to analyze.
So I'm going to jump
over to BigQuery here.
And I'm on the data set that
I just set up to configure.
Its Cloud Costs, and there are
a number of tables in there.
I'll explain some
of the other ones.
But the one we care about
is the Billing Export v1.
So since October
of last year when
billing export became
GA and everybody got it,
it's versioned as v1.
Prior to that is the couple
of years of billing data
that we had before with some
different headers and whatnot.
Billing export. v1
is this table set.
And if I preview this
table, you can kind of
get a feel for
what we're actually
saving to BigQuery here.
So for every service, for
every project, for every SKU,
there's a line
item for every hour
of what that was built up with.
So I can see, I've got
Compute Engine, storage
of an image in a
project of this project,
labels that I've applied
to that resource--
so you can split resources
by custom labels.
And then I actually get
the cost that it was--
so the cost and the currency
and the usage amount.
So having all this
data in BigQuery
is going to allow me to actually
build graphs and do analytics
over that.
So how did we do this before is
probably an important question?
Well, I'm sure some others
have spreadsheets like this.
But we have these sheets
that date back to 2011.
And every month, we would
get the Google bill,
and we would sit there
in the spreadsheet,
and we'd type every line
item in for every row.
And when we saw things
that got screwed up,
we were like, oh, no, we've
got to do something about that.
So there are lots
of examples in here
where we jumped $10,000
a month on a row item.
And then three months later,
we were down to $3,000
a month on it, where we added
$5,000 in front-end instances.
And it was always a struggle to
actually do anything proactive
with it because we were always
reacting to-- uh-oh, big bill.
How do we handle this one now?
So we wasted a lot of
beer on these resources.
We've made that back
significantly by doing
more real-time analysis on it.
So the next step, once we
have an export in BigQuery,
is to actually use Data Studio.
So I'm going to
go in Data Studio,
and I'm going to start
a brand-new blank sheet.
DALE HOPKINS: So this
is for the group here.
How many of you are currently
using a billing export?
OK.
DALE BIRTCH: Nice.
DALE HOPKINS: And
how many of you
are actually tying this
today to Data Studio today?
OK, cool.
DALE BIRTCH: Nice.
So once we open up
Data Studio here,
I'm going to give it
a new data source.
It's pretty straightforward.
It's going to ask me which
source I want to use.
That'll be a BigQuery
in this situation.
I'm going to find my project
and table name that I set up
in the first place.
Data set here, costs--
and I'm going to choose
my v1 export, which is
what I configured in my save.
So this is going to
connect this BigQuery
table to my Data Studio sheets.
Now, the first thing
I'm going to do
is-- record count I
don't really care about.
I really want to do
everything by cost.
So I'm just going to
Disable record count
and say, Add This to Report.
So now I have a
blank Data Studio
report that is connected
to all of my billing data.
So from here, I can do something
like draw a time series graph
to represent what is my cost.
So I start a brand new graph.
It's automatically going to
figure out that usage start
time is what I'm graphing.
And I can see my daily
cost in this graph
over the last month for all
of my App Engine projects
and all of my resources.
From there, I probably want
to give a little more value,
like a scorecard, to say, what
is the totals for this period?
So we're just going to
draw a scorecard here.
That will give me my totals
for that time period.
And it's running
its BigQuery queries
in the background to calculate
all of that information that
gets shown on the screen here.
It should be noted, you do get
billed for the BigQuery queries
and for storing the data.
It's super minimal.
I've tried to
calculate it before,
and we're in single dollars
a day over the last few years
that we have data in there.
If you were to query
something like logs,
it's going to be
much more expensive.
I've made that mistake before.
Data Studio is not the
right tool for that.
So now that I've got a total
[INAUDIBLE] cost on here,
I probably want to give a
little more control to the user.
So let's put a
daterange selector on.
Again, it's the same thing.
You just drag on a
daterange selector,
and you can set a
default daterange for it.
I usually do something along
the lines of the last 14 days.
So now I have a graph that shows
me my totals for the last 14
days and lets a
user configure that.
I also want to do something like
give them a filter option so
that the user can
choose which projects
they want to do, which projects
they want to drill down into,
and explore some of
their own metrics.
So I'm going to
put this up here.
Its dimension is going to
be the project ID by cost.
So at this point,
I have a graph that
lets me choose
dateranges, shows me
the total for that
daterange, and lets
me pick an individual project.
So I could say I just want
to see this one project.
So I'm looking at a project
now, and I've got an anomaly.
That doesn't look
like the last 14 days.
How do I actually know,
is that normal, or not?
From there, we can start
to use some of the tools
that Data Studio provides.
So if I look at
any graph in here,
I can put a compare
on that says,
look at it over the previous
period and graph that as well.
So now I've got a light blue
line and a dark blue line,
the light blue line being what
that range was for the last 14
days, and the dark
blue line being
what we're actually running
in this current time period.
So now I when I view this
graph and grab my project,
I can tell, is that something
that I should actually
care about and investigate?
Yes, it probably is because
it's an anomaly to what we
expect it to be in that period.
So this gives you
a really basic--
I have a graph now that I can
say, share it with a team.
We can put it on a TV in a
room and represent their one
individual project.
This brings in all
of the identity
and Access Management
of the Google Docs
that you could say, here,
this person can have it.
You can share a link
outside of the organization.
And you can widely
distribute those graphs
and not have to be
concerned about permissions
or giving access to
projects that you wouldn't
want to give otherwise.
So from here, I'm going to
look at some of the options
that you can do outside
of building your own.
So Google actually has
given a set of templates
for visualizing your time
spent in Data Studio.
They wrote this blog
post on it and link you
to an example report.
If you read through
this blog post,
it basically walks you
through the same set
up-- exporting your data,
looking at your data,
and then using this billing
report demo link, which
opens up this billing
report in Data Studio
that you can clone
into your organization,
so make a copy of the report.
And it's going to ask you
to set up your data sources.
The instructions are all in
the blog on how to do that.
But we're going to
grab a billing export.
I believe the second one
is a spending trends,
and the third one is a BigQuery
audit source for billing.
And cloning that report
then gives you something
to start with that
has all of your data
in a prepopulated dashboard.
And we don't heavily
leverage this internally,
because it's broken
down mostly by product--
by your BigQuery, by your App
Engine, by your cloud costs--
and we tend to break
things down by project
because teams are
responsible for projects, not
for individual products across
the whole Google Platform.
But it's a great
spot to actually grab
this visualization.
You can copy graphs out of it.
You can look at exactly how
they have designed the graphs
and what data powers it
and grab ideas from there
to populate your own
custom dashboards that
would be more useful in your
organization or your type
of setup here.
So I can basically see,
by project, my spending
by day, and over time in here.
So I can jump to
Projects, and it's
got a bunch of nice bar
graphs and pie graphs
around how we're
actually spending money
once it comes up here.
So this is a great source
for finding information
and figuring out how to
actually build dashboards
within Data Studio.
We built our own from scratch,
initially, to start with.
We find that we can
get a more custom view.
You can tailor something
specific to a team
and give that to them, and then
they can own that information.
So I'm going to jump
over another tab
and actually look at
what we have built.
So we've got 20 pages in
this Data Studio sheet
that are different reports
for different purposes.
So we've got a total
cost report that
breaks down our
costs by environment
and shows it compared
to the last two weeks
with our cost and our credits.
This is on a TV in
our atrium where
every person in the
organization sees it
so that anybody walking
can be empowered
to go, what happened there,
and ask that question.
And we want to
encourage teams to ask
that question because then you
take ownership of the project.
You can make those changes
to really drive down costs
and manage them over time.
So from there, we've
got individual projects
and also showing the
same type of overlays
with the last periods of time.
So if we looked at
something like data storage
rates and storage, we have
spikes every week here.
And having the context of what
it was over the last period
tells me that those spikes
are probably normal.
We do bulk work at that point.
But if I just saw
the spike otherwise,
I might spend some
time investigating,
similar to this Google Cloud
Endpoints or service control
line item that was $150
higher than expected that day.
That's probably worth
me investigating.
And sure enough,
there was a Pub/Sub
that was failing and
causing that to retry
and additional traffic.
But I probably don't
want to actually look
at the extra $150 we spent on
data store reads and writes
in that period, because I
can see that they're normal.
That gives me the context to
look at our data over time.
I use a lot of
this data as an SRE
to see what's happening
in our organization.
So for example, our Cloud
SQL costs jumped here.
That probably means,
to me, somebody
added a new Cloud SQL
database or changed the way
it was scaling.
And if they haven't
talked to me about that,
I'm probably concerned
about how they set up
security on that
Cloud SQL database
and what they're
actually using that for.
Maybe it's a Dev database
that they provisioned
with production resources.
It's $5 a day.
That's not a huge number, but
if it can be a smaller instance
type, we'll move that down.
So generally, when I'm looking
at Data Studio reports,
there are two different things
I'm looking for, either slow
burn-- things that are
eating up cost over time
and just very, very
slowly creeping,
or sudden changes
within our billing data
where something spiked
and we're trying
to catch it before it grows
and goes out of control.
If I look through some examples
that we've had in the past year
or so--
I had talked about
the data store
reads matching almost exactly
with the previous period.
That's not a concern.
Cloud Endpoints spiking, that
is more of a concern for me.
If I go to something
like this graph--
this is an external
blog that we host.
And it also hosts some
of our internal KPIs
that get run against
BigQuery every day
and say how many
reports did we make?
How many customers signed--
those types of things.
And that's a BigQuery job that
happens under Cloud Tasks.
And in this case,
February 13 of this year,
the query to BigQuery
was successful,
but the task wasn't completing.
So the task was failing
and then retrying.
And the next hour, we would
try and collect stats again.
It would still call out to
BigQuery and fail and retry.
And we get a graph
that kind of looks
like this where, over the course
of a weekend, in a few days,
we went from spending
like $15 a day
on analysis to spending $325.
And having a billing report
in front of a team-- somebody
looked at it, and went, oh,
yeah, we should go fix that.
Because that failing task isn't
just a single failing task.
It's actually costing us
hundreds of dollars a day.
Similarly, this is
the same project.
We had just started doing
some development on it,
and it is one of
our few projects
that uses App Engine Flex.
And you have to spin
up your own machines
and spin down your own machines.
It doesn't just
take care of that
when you move traffic around.
So in this case, they were
deploying new versions
and failing to spin
down the old versions.
So after a few days, we realized
that the cost in that project
was climbing, and
we were getting
billed for more flex instance
hours and flex RAM costs
that we were expecting to.
Just have that
chat with the team.
Hey, you guys are
spending more money
than you're expecting to here.
What's going on?
These are the line items
that you are using here.
DALE HOPKINS: We've
had lots of examples.
You guys have
probably heard this.
We had a development team.
And what they wanted to do was
some load testing on a service,
so they spun up the
biggest possible VM
they could find on GCP.
They ran all of their tests.
And then one of them
forgot to spin it down
at the end of the day.
And it doesn't take long before
you spin something like that
up, and the, all of a
sudden, your test projects,
you're seeing this
shark fin like this.
And this is how Dale ends
up finding these things.
And so it's actually really
helpful because a lot
of the stuff that,
at our office,
we're pretty open with
permissions on developers,
so they can create machines.
They can do lots of stuff.
And this kind of helps
catch those anomalies,
that, it's, like, not
part of normal operations.
DALE BIRTCH: Yeah, and another
one that's super common is slow
burn-- so where something
just creeps up over time, over
and over again, and
you don't really
notice that it's costing
you a whole bunch of money.
If I look at a project here--
which one am I in?
Our BigQuery costs for storage--
if you look at our long-term
storage costs here in the green
line, it went up by basically
$0.50 a day and had been
climbing for quite a while.
And we realized that
bad retention policies
happen all the time.
When you create a retention
policy in BigQuery,
it's only on newly-created
tables after that.
It doesn't take effect
to all the old tables.
So we had terabytes
of data hanging around
in BigQuery that we
really didn't care about.
But because we didn't make
the buckets with a retention
policy, they were just hanging
around forever and ever.
And we sat down and well,
this just keeps increasing.
We have to do
something about that.
It's not increasing in
value to the organization.
So let's write some scripts,
actually hit BigQuery,
and expire all those tables,
set expiry times on them.
And once they expire, the
cost drops back down again.
We've seen it in projects where
our cloud storage cost will
creep up over time, and
next thing you know,
we're spending $30 a
day in cloud storage.
Well, we did backups every
single night for multiple years
and never cleaned up a
backup, because there was just
no retention policy
on those buckets.
Another favorite of
mine that we'll find,
looking into individual line
items, is unused IP addresses.
You don't pay for static IPs
in Google's infrastructure
unless you don't have them
assigned to something.
And then you start
paying for them.
So it's a burden to
spend-- it's not expensive.
It's $5 or $6 a month.
But when you have 30 or
40 of them hanging around
because somebody
deprovisioned something,
it adds up over time.
And that's beer that we could be
drinking instead of spending it
on static IP addresses
we're just not using.
So I tend to use our cloud costs
as a set of metrics over what's
going on in my environment.
Newly created items, workloads
that I'm not expecting,
sudden changes in cost--
they're usually
tied to something
a development team is doing and
gives me that resource that I
can go talk to the
development team and say,
hey guys, what's going on here?
And it also brings that
transparency to the teams,
that, they can own
their own costs.
They can look at their
graphs over time.
They can be responsible
for those things.
And it kind of pushes that
this is their project, not
something that we're
administrating and telling
them to work on.
DALE HOPKINS: The
permissions thing
is also, like, it's just huge.
Because you don't
necessarily want
to provide access to all this
billing data to everybody.
But you can provide
these great views.
And Dale mentioned
that you can even
do these things externally.
So if you want to share
these with somebody else,
the permission model
is just a huge deal.
And for everybody in here,
the sooner you can give people
telemetry on what
they're doing--
I mean, you don't even have
to tell developers that they
should be worried about costs.
If they can actually
see the costs--
and, I mean, they
see the shark fin.
A lot of the time, you're going
to find developers take action
on their own stuff if
they know about this.
And so, in a lot of ways,
what this is all about
is just bringing
that data to people.
Because, in a lot of ways,
people do a lot of bad things
because they just
didn't realize it.
And so it, basically, it's
producing more safety,
in terms of, like, when you
do things at the office,
and you know that you're
going to see the cost
change if you did something
wrong, it feels a lot safer.
People are going to
push more comfortably.
And that sort of thing is
really important to us.
DALE BIRTCH: One of the
points I want to also make
is with regards to the way
that the data is stored.
Every project
ingests billing data
and puts it to BigQuery
slightly differently.
So in Lotus, if I look at
one of my production graphs,
the last day of most of our App
Engine costs all kind of drop
off here.
The App Engine doesn't actually
have a point yet for this day.
App Engine's typically about
two days before it ends up
in our billing export.
So there is a lag time.
The same lag time is
there in the reports.
So if you're doing
forecasting or something,
you kind of have to
change your dates
back to being a full set of
data that you're not having
that zero point at the end.
Any of these graphs, I
can go and edit and put
a linear regression line
across it within Data Studio
here and say, here's my
trend line that's linear
and then say, view this report.
Well, it's always going
to be trending down
if I have that zero
data point at the end.
The guys that are
doing the forecasting
have compensated
for that and handle
it much better
than we can in Data
Studio with a simple
linear progression.
So if you have the opportunity
to use the forecasting tools,
they are better than
what you'll probably
build yourself in here.
But this can give you
a pretty basic view
on what you have been doing
over the course of a month.
STEPHEN ELLIOTT: All right.
Well, thank you very much for
attending the [INAUDIBLE]..
[MUSIC PLAYING]